Rețelele neurale sunt o clasă puternică de algoritmi de machine learning
și vin în multe varietăți
nu există nicio modalitate de a acorda atenția cuvenită rețelelor neurale
într-un video introductiv
ca acesta; aici vom identifica doar câteva componente cheie
ale unei rețele neurale și fluxul general de lucru
ca să înțelegem cum poate contribui calculul cuantic
rețeaua neurală este un graf conectat de neuroni
un neuron este practic doar un element care conține un număr
și acel număr este adesea numit activare — cât de
activ sau inactiv este neuronul
neuronii sunt organizați în straturi
primul strat este stratul de intrare
iar ultimul este stratul de ieșire
între ele se află straturi folosite la procesare, numite
straturi ascunse; activarea stratului
de intrare este pur și simplu încărcată direct din datele de analizat
cum ar fi umbrele pixelilor dintr-o imagine
activările următorului strat ascuns sunt determinate
de neuronii din stratul de intrare
și de ponderi, simbolizate prin liniile care conectează toți neuronii
din stratul de intrare cu toți neuronii din
stratul următor; cu alte cuvinte, determinăm activarea
unui neuron din stratul ascuns
printr-o sumă ponderată a tuturor
activărilor de intrare; putem
aplica și un bias, o deplasare —
s-ar putea să vrem să activăm un neuron
din stratul ascuns nu doar dacă suma ponderată este
pozitivă, ci doar dacă depășește un prag mare
apoi aplicăm adesea o funcție complicată pentru a obține o activare
între zero și unu, cum ar fi tangenta hiperbolică
sau uneori altceva, o
unitate liniară rectificată; nu trebuie să te
îngrijorezi prea mult de acestea acum; singurul
lucru important de reținut despre aceste funcții
este că sunt neliniare
astfel încât rețeaua în ansamblu conține atât componente liniare
cât și neliniare
aceeași sumă ponderată a activărilor, de data aceasta
pornind de la activările
primului strat ascuns cu noile ponderi
se extinde până la următorul strat ascuns
acest proces continuă până la stratul final, care este ieșirea
stratul de ieșire are neuroni corespunzători
categoriilor, iar activările ne spun
cât de sigură este rețeaua de clasificare
deci categoriile de ieșire în analiza unei imagini ar putea fi
câine, pisică, hamster și așa mai departe
iar o activare de 0,95 pe
neuronul „câine" ar indica un grad ridicat de certitudine că
imaginea este cu un câine; s-ar putea să-ți pornești rețeaua neurală
cu un set aleatoriu de ponderi
și biasuri, sau de la o configurație inițială rezonabilă cunoscută
dar ideea este să verifici
cât de bine clasifică rețeaua ta neurală lucrurile
și să o îmbunătățești; folosim o funcție de cost pentru a descrie
cum se abate rețeaua noastră neurală de la
clasificarea corectă; asta implică calculul
diferenței dintre valoarea reală a unei imagini
de exemplu o valoare de unu pe neuronul
pentru câine și zero pe toți ceilalți neuroni de ieșire
și valorile prezise
facem suma peste toate categoriile
deci urmărim nu doar dacă categoria corectă a fost
cel mai activată, ci putem
urmări și dacă activările incorecte sunt reduse
facem suma peste toate exemplele din setul nostru de antrenament
și obținem un cost; apoi
variem parametrii, cum ar fi ponderile din fiecare strat
între toți neuronii și biasurile pe toți neuronii
rutinele clasice de optimizare sunt folosite
pentru a căuta un minim local în funcția de cost
dacă nu se face nimic pentru a reduce complexitatea acestui lucru
îți poți imagina ce
spațiu astronomic de parametri am creat aici
gândește-te la o rețea neurală proiectată să analizeze imagini cu
doar o mie de pixeli; această rețea neurală ar putea avea o mie
de neuroni de intrare, un singur strat ascuns
și ieșire binară, cum ar fi pisică sau câine
acesta este cel mai simplu caz cu putință
și tot corespunde la o mie înmulțit cu o mie
adică un milion de ponderi între straturile de intrare și cel ascuns
și alte două mii între
straturile ascuns și de ieșire
posibil și o mie sau
ceva biasuri; deci această rețea neurală simplă ar corespunde
la bine peste un milion de parametri; deși, ca să fiu corect,
algoritmii moderni fac de obicei simplificări
în rețelele neurale clasice
și există domenii întregi dedicate să facă această minimizare
posibilă și chiar eficientă
dar rămâne faptul că aceasta este o problemă de
dimensionalitate foarte ridicată
iar antrenarea unei rețele neurale
poate fi foarte consumatoare de timp
și costisitoare; o rețea neurală cuantică, sau QNN,
funcționează prin încărcarea inițială a datelor de intrare
și apoi prin aplicarea unor quantum circuits
corespunzătoare ponderilor dintre straturi
și în final un strat de măsurători
câteva aspecte cheie despre asta: datele
de încărcare și ponderările sunt operații liniare
dar măsurătorile sunt neliniare
deci, ca în rețelele neurale clasice, avem
atât componente liniare, cât și neliniare
de asemenea, quantum circuits de ponderi
au în continuare parametri variaționali
deci există în continuare o minimizare clasică de efectuat
desigur, am zgâriat doar suprafața rețelelor neurale cuantice
dar sperăm să continui să înveți despre aplicațiile
rețelelor neurale cuantice
și alte aplicații de machine learning cuantic
cu IBM Quantum